I think the legacy of Mandela you know
will still be with us for I think the
kids to come for many reason which are
linked to his history but to the way he
understood power and led a country which
was a divided country coming from
outside appetite from a man who had been
locked up for 20 27 years of course I
think he had not solve all the problems
South Africa is facing and of course
he's bigger than South Africa he's
bigger than the continent his legacy is
the legacy for all of humanity actually
to build on and I think his first legacy
this is a man came out of jail and was
ready to talk to people who jailed him
and he was ready because he's mostly a
man over 60s 60s defined by radical ease
and you see it reading the I&C fatter
out of jail he was able to adjust to a
completely new moment it just has an
individual but also it just has a
politician and what everybody predicted
he single-handedly dealt with that South
Africa will not go for a racial civil
war that the space was open for
negotiation space was open for
compromises estate for was open to
invent a new world and I think it's the
most important element Mandela was
behind the eye
that it is possible to invent a new
world it is possible to turn enemies not
into friends but enemies into partners
that it was possible pulling different
memories different Heritage's together
it was possible actually to reinvent
South Africa in particular to reinvent
an idea of South Africa and you see
quite clearly how astute he was but how
also you know I think federative he was
you know by saying that this is a
complex country and this is where you
should do things but second element
which seems to me important is what the
most important of his legacy is this man
decided to do one turn and leave and
this is a revolution in Africa you could
have stayed until his death it could
have it because he's already ver myth he
is already even when he left power he is
he remain the person to go to in a
moment of crisis a person to go to when
you need an advise a person to go to
when you need a voice to mobilize so
Mandela is very powerful voice but it's
a voice of a democratic politician is
the voice of a man who was able to say
at a point I have been too long in jail
I have done what I had to do to help for
transition now I'm too old to remain
president I have to pass the baton to a
new generation and he did a great job
passing the baton living and never
commenting on what was going on there
but still staying on the stage walking
through his foundation to address very
important
issues at the level of South Africa but
also advil available becoming the world
actor actually probably in the late
twentieth century the other person would
have played kind of overall at least
advil at least yellow level of the world
stage is Bill Clinton and the third
thing would seem very trivial but which
is also very important is when he
decided to just you know drop his with
suits and ties of a formal uniform of
President to wear with very colorful
shirts you know and in return actually
through his dressing return to a state
of the ordinary of an of an ordinary you
know of an ordinary citizen of a world
and returned home to live to live his
life as as an ordinary man who can
cultivate after walking for the future
of a nation after setting the foundation
for the future of South Africa actually
to go back to his past and rediscover
probably with choice of you know being
back with your people and rediscovering
a life you haven't you haven't lived and
and I think he's something very very
important politically of course you know
we can actually discuss some of the
choices he made you know oh also the
kind of result he has you know rich but
something which is which will remain
with us and remain with history is the
way in which not only he ensured a kind
of
peaceful transition in a context as you
know of violence but the fact also the
way he left power and hold himself has
powerful wise man